Andrew Simmons joins us live now from
Westminster in London and well home
secretary Sue Ella bravaman has resigned
so just how big a surprise is this
it's a big it's a big development uh
suela bravaman uh Home Secretary is well
it's the second uh big uh a loss in the
government to top post uh within less
than a week uh so quasi quateng uh six
days ago and now swella bravaman she was
on the right of the party she is a
former chair of the European research
Group which is in certainly a right-wing
side the proponents of of brexit uh they
backed uh Boris Johnson very much so and
they were also uh big supporters uh of
those tax cuts which have all been trash
now we do have uh the text of of a tweet
she's just posted a few minutes ago uh
and I'm just reading it now
um she said that she had posted an
official document on her personal email
about migration uh and this uh uh was
sent to a personal colleague this
contributed a breach of ministerial
rules as soon as I reported the mistake
uh right away
um I then moved on to decide to use uh
well to decided to resign because she
wanted to keep
um herself performing to the highest
standards of office and now this is it
is a surprise uh is it as simple and as
a mistake she made but it it could well
be that this government does not
tolerate any uh sort of conduct that
isn't uh strictly in line with
ministerial codes of conduct so perhaps
it's as simple as that but it's easy to
look at this and think well is this is
this possibly
more than a coincidence in the sense
that that sowella bravaman was very much
against the moves by Jeremy Hunt to move
in and do this Jeremy Hunt comes from a
different grouping of the parties a
one-nation conservative and we're
hearing now that Grant shaps uh form a
transport Minister uh in Boris Johnson's
uh government uh is likely to be
appointed to replace her so Grant shaps
more of a moderate person he's not
certainly not in the ERG grouping so is
this factional in some ways are we
seeing now
um this government going more moderate
and moving towards the the center of the
party and not the right these are all
possibilities it's very early in the day
to form big conclusions but what has to
be said this is a blow to Liz truss only
a short time after she had what the
party regards as a reasonably good
performance in prime minister's
questions uh where the labor leader Kia
stammer was laying into her she held her
ground they say they think she's
certainly uh used a boxing analogy that
she is a fighter not a quitter and that
analogy of course I would say applies
this way in that she certainly uh wasn't
giving any knockout Blows By kirst armor
but then starmer went on points because
of the chaos that's been going on in
this government and as he described the
fairy tale economics as you were Hearing
in Aurora's report earlier on it was a
real fraccar in the House of Commons
a huge day obviously for trust with the
question time being uh pretty combative
to say the least and now of resignation
of one of her top ministers I mean how
much longer do you think that trusts can
hold on for
well the feeling was that uh after her
performance in the House of Commons that
she bought some time uh I think the
general consensus is that she will have
to go it's such a colossal uh crash of
the economy and she she tried to blame
it on uh her Chancellor the Finance
Minister a quasi quateng she fired him
he was a personal friend
um but then she was in charge and she
knew full well she was going ahead with
cuts in tax that hadn't really been
costed out and of course it caused a
major financial crisis uh as she's done
the conservative party not only big
damage in terms of its credibility but
also uh in terms of of her own status
well she does look lightweight and that
is that is really the situation but but
more on bravaman uh bravaman uh is a is
a lawyer by profession she is you know
well qualified to be a a home secretary
in charge of what is effectively an
interior Ministry and other other terms
she had been passing she'd been put
pushing through uh public order act
which is uh quite a right-wing move to
clamp down on protests uh slightly more
extreme protests such as environmental
protesters gluing themselves to
buildings and and causing a traffic
chaos but coming down hard on them she
has caused ruffled a lot of collars in
that respect respect she had also been
outspoken about the u-turn on the higher
rated tax you know the rich uh getting a
tax break basically she'd she thought
that that was a very Justified move on
the part of the government and that was
one of the first things to be given a
U-turn by Liz truss so certainly she is
from a part of the party
that is uh that is not really uh the
flavor right now uh there are there is
even some suggestions that if there was
an early suggestion uh that the Jeremy
Hunt the Present Finance Minister had
actually been behind moves to get her
out but that's not in any way confirmed
okay thank you very much that's Andrew
Simmons for us uh in London surely
plenty more twists and turns to come
thank you